اعلنت الحكومه لبريطانيه فرض عقوبات جديده
على مسؤولينا وكيانات ايرانيه لدورهم في
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في البلاد
واوضحت لندن ان العقوبات شملت تجميد اصول
قائد القوات البريه في الجيش الايراني
ونائب القائد العام للحرس الثوري ونائب
قائد ميليشيا البسيج وحظرهم من السفر
كما قررت الحكومه البريطانيه تجميد اصول
الفسيج مؤكده ان العقوبات تعكس ادانه
العنف الذي يمارسه النظام بحق شعبه بما في
ذلك اعدام لبريطاني الايراني علي رضا اكبر
بدوره قال وزير الخارجيه لبريطاني جيمس
كليبرري ان بلاده فرضت 50 عقوبه جديده
مرتبطه بانتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران
منذ مقتل مهسى امين
ومع استمرار النظام في قمع التظاهرات
الاحتجاجيه اعلن الاتحاد الاوروبي
الموافقه على فرض حزمه عقوبات جديده ضد
ايران مشيرا الى ان الحزمه الجديده تستهدف
قاده ايرانيين متهمين باستخدام القمع ضد
المتظاهرين
وجدد الاتحاد الاوروبي رفضه لاستخدام
القوه بشكل وحشيه من قبل السلطات
الايرانيه ضد المتظاهرين السلمي
[موسيقى]
رئيس البرلمان الايراني محمد باقر قريباف
اعتبر ان العقوبات الامريكيه على طهران
وموسكو تشكل اكبر تهديدا في الوقت الرحم
واضاف قالبه في مؤتمر صحفي مع رئيس مجلس
النواب الروسي فيات سلاف فولودين ان
الضغوط على البلدين تتطلب العمل المشترك
والتعامل الاستراتيجي لتجاوز المرحله
بدوره اعتبر ان العقوبات الامريكيه تساهم
في دفع العلاقات بين البلدين قائلا ان
الحظر الذي تفرضه امريكا وحلفائها سيدفع
الى المزيد من الانسجام والتعاون بين
موسكو
هذا وحذر وزير خارجيه النمسا من ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي لا يريد اي سباق تسلح في
المنطقه في الوقت الذي تتحرك فيه ايران
بالاتجاه الخاطئ وترسل المسيرات والمعدات
الحربيه الى روسيا
ح النووي في منطقه الخليج ايران بسرعه
كبيره في الاتجاه الخاطئ من خلال شحنه
الطائره بدون طيار والمعدات الحربيه الى
روسيا وما تقوم به من قمع لشعبها لذا فان
العقوبات ضروريه
تمام انا وزير الخارجيه النمسا عن ادراج
37 شخصا وكيانا جديدا على قائمه عقوبات
الاتحاد الاوروبي مشيرا الى ان هذه
الاجراءات ستستمر بسبب تورط ايران في
جرائم يحارب بشكل غير مباشر
على قائمه عقوبه الاتحاد الاوروبي وستمر
هذه الاجراءات علينا مواصله الضغط طالما
ان ايران تشارك بشكل غير مباشر في جرائم
الحرب وترسل طائره بدون طيار وربما صواريخ
الى روسيا
الى بروكسل حيث مراسل العربي نور الدين
الفريدي يتابع كل هذه التطورات نور اهلا
وسهلا بك جديده التحركات والمواقف
الاوروبيه نور فيما خاص العقوبات الجديده
على ايران وهل فعلا يمكن للاتحاد الاوروبي
ان يتبنى توصيه البرلمان بتصنيفرس الثوري
على لائحه الارهاب ام لا موقف جوزيف بورن
اليوم يعيد خلط الاوراق من جديد
يوضح الموقف الصحيح
والقانوني يبقى سياسي ممكن نتحدث فيه
لاحقا جزء بوريل قال ان القرار بشان ادراج
الحرس الثوري الايراني في قائمه الارهاب
يرتبط اولا من قبل كل شيء بصدور حكم من
قضائيا في دوله من دول الاتحاد الاوروبيه
على ان تنقل هذه الدوله هذا طلبها او هذا
الحكم الى طاوله الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى
اليوم لا لم تحاكم اي دوله من دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي
متهمين مرتبطين مباشره
بالحارس الثوري الايراني
يعني قاعده اساسيه لا يمكن تجاوزها باي
حال من الاحوال لان اي قرار اخر يمكن فيه
امام محكمه العدد الاوروبي ومن هناك فان
جوزيف
كل الغموض كل الجدل
الذي دار على مداء الايام الماضيه همم
بسبب عدم وضوح الموقف من الناحيه
القانونيه طيب لكن
سنعود اليها ولكن في هذه النقطه الا يعتبر
ذلك تراجع عن اوروبيا او للنقل مخرج
للاوروبيين لعدم تصنيف الحارس الثوري على
الاقل في هذه المرحله على لائحه الارهاب
وبالتالي الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يستفز ايران
اطلاقا له اطلاقا لا لان الحرس الثوري
الايراني كبار المسؤولين فيه حتى في قائمه
اليوم هناك خمسه جنرالات من جرارات الحارس
السوري
الان في هاته الحزمه الرابعه من العقوبات
التي صدرت قبل نحو ساعه في الجريده
الرسميه الاوروبيه واثني عشر كيانا نتابعا
على الحدث الدوري هذا من ناحيه من ناحيه
اخرى الحاله الثوري المدرج في قوائم
العقوبات حول سوريا مدرج في قوائم مسيرات
الى روسيا مدرج منذ العام 2010 مثل ما
اكدت وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه كاترين كلنا
ندرس منذ العام 2010 في قائمه العقوبات
المتصله بحذر الانتشار النووي والحرس
الثوري مسؤول عن همم عن همم عن نشر هذه
التكنولوجيا واستخدام الصواريخ البالستيه
وتطويره لبرنامج الصواريخ الرئيسيه رغم
قراراته وبالتالي همم القول من انا
الاتحاد الاوروبيه يتراجعوا يخضع للضغوط
لا غير صحيح يعني
الموضوع هو
المنهجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي هو استهداف
المسؤولين في الحارس الثوري بشكل منتظما
وهذه الحزمه الرابعه تؤكد هذا الاتجاه
التصعيد من جانب الاتحاد الاوروبي ردا على
قمعي ايران المنهج للمتظاهرين بالتالي لكن
المثل الاخرى من الناحيه الدبلوماسيه
النقاش مفتوح بين الدبلوماسيين الاوروبيين
انا انا نور
هل نتوقع ان تقوم دوله اوروبيه ما في
الايام المقبله باصدار هذا مثل هكذا قرار
همم قائد ضد الحرس الثوري وبالتالي يعطي
مشروعيه للاتحاد لان يتبنى همم هذا القرار
ويصنف الحارس على لائحه الارهاب املا هذا
السبعه
يعني مستبعد حضرتك فضلت قلت الايام
المقبله هذا مستبعد في الاسابيع والاشهر
المقبله لان نحن لان الاتحاد الاوروبي
قائم على اسس ومبادئ دوله القانون
وبالتالي هناك مثلا هناك تحقيقات جاريه في
المانيا يتعلق بحاله
محدده ربما تتصل ربما لها سلات بالحارس
السوري الايراني هذه تحقيقات حسب زميلاتنا
في برلين ستستمر ربما اشهر واشهر ربما من
هنا الى نهايه العالم
شغل القضاء شغل يعني همم والقضاء مستقل في
نهايه في هذه المساله وبالتالي يجب همم
الاخذ بان الاعتبار بان هاتي مساله اساسيه
ممكن من اركان التي يقوم عليها الاتحاد هي
احترام ما بدا دوله القانون الان اذا سمحت
همم
ورد حديثا يعني قبل ساعات في قائمه
العقوبات همم الرابعه ضد همم الحاله
الثوري الايراني خمسه جرارات اليوم وهم
مثلا همم
احمد رئيس فريق كربلاء في الحرس الثوري
الايراني همم ايضا احمد عظيم رئيس قسم
النجف الاشرف في الحارس الثوري الايراني
عباس مرتضى نائب قائد الحرس الثوري
الايراني
مسلم معين رئيس مقر البسيج او سكنه البسيج
او هي ديكورات التي تبع البسيج في الامن
السيبراني قائد الحارس الثوري في محافظه
باريس الثاني قائد الحارس الثوري في
محافظه كربلاء
17 هم من المحافدين ورجال الامن
والمسؤولين في الاذاعه والتلفزيون
التكنولوجيا الكيانات هي ايضا همم اكثر من
20 الى 20 كيان في هذه القائمه 12 كيانا
تابعا للحرس الثوري الايراني
حقوق الانسان في ايران وصلت الان الى مئه
وواحد 161 مسؤولا ايرانيا و32 كيانا
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من بروكسل مراسل العربي
نور الدين الفريدي شكرا جزيلا لك نور على
كل هذه متابعه